des dégradations sur un golf dans le
département voisin de la Vienne le
convoi de l'eau poursuit son périple 800
militants écologistes sont arrivés ce
soir en Sud Touraine à dolulossec
précisément ça ne s'invente pas
direction ensuite tours demain toujours
à vélo ou en tracteur objectif de cette
manifestation exigée la fin des mégas
bassines agricoles Faustine Luneau
[Musique]
c'est au son des klaxons et dans la
bonne humeur que le convoi débarque dans
le bourg de Paul mie l'heure de la pause
déjeuner a sonné pour c'est presque 800
cyclistes et la vingtaine de tracteurs
un rassemblement militant pour la
protection de cette ressource naturelle
vitale l'eau il va y avoir des gens qui
vont être privés d'eau et en fait
manifester le fait que on n'est pas
d'accord pour qu'il y ait une
appropriation et qu'au contraire faut
qu'on repense des trucs pour qu'on se la
partage tous ça m'a paru hyper important
on traverse plein de villages où on peut
parler avec les habitants et on traverse
aussi tout un territoire qui est dévasté
par l'agro industrie on fait à peu près
50 km par jour c'est pas c'est une bonne
moyenne qui se fait après il fait très
très chaud
partie il y a trois jours de sainte
Soline sous l'impulsion des soulèvements
de la terre de bassines non merci et de
la Confédération paysanne ils sont
actuellement en Indre-et-Loire
l'objectif parcourir 450 km en 7 jours
et rejoindre Orléans où se trouve le
siège de l'agence de l'oloir Bretagne
l'Agence de l'Eau participe à financer à
hauteur de 50% avec de l'argent public
des projets de méga bassines qui sont
absolument nocifs qui sont là pour
maintenir un modèle agro-industriel qui
est délétère et pour accaparer
privatiser l'eau aujourd'hui on pense
que l'Agence de l'eau c'est ce qu'on va
demander doit absolument s'arrêter ici
et maintenant de financer les méga
bassines sur le chemin le convoi
s'arrête à chaque étape pour soutenir
des luttes contre certains procédés
d'agriculture industrielles ou pour
montrer des alternatives ce soir par
exemple ils seront accueillis par la
ferme de bellaitre à dolussec une
coopérative paysanne en plein préparatif
c'est l'occasion pour nous de montrer
qu'il y a aussi un enjeu de promotion de
l'agriculture paysanne et de mise en
avant des modèles agricoles alternatifs
pour que y ait assez de place pour que
les cyclistes puissent camper manger
se laver et effectivement là ce qui se
prépare c'est qu'il va y avoir le
bancaire pour manger un accueil festif
avant de repartir demain matin direction
tours le convoi se rassemblera devant le
tribunal où seront jugés plusieurs
militants écologistes pour les jets de
peinture sur la préfecture en mars
dernier